they include a book called anti-racist
baby
uh by ibrahim kindy
and
there are portions of this book
that i find
really quite remarkable one portion of
the book
says babies
are taught
to be racist or anti-racist there is no
neutrality
another portion of the book
they recommend the babies confess
when being racist
now this is a book that is taught at
georgetown day school
to students in pre-k through second
grade so four through seven years old
um
do you agree with this book that is
being taught with kids that the babies
are racist
senator
i do not believe
that any child
should be made to feel
as though they are racist or though they
are
not valued or though they are less than
that they're victims that they're
oppressors i don't
believe in any of that but what i will
say
is that when you
asked me whether or not this was taught
in
schools critical race theory
my understanding is that critical race
theory as an academic theory is taught
in law schools and
to the extent that you were asking the
question i understood you to be
addressing public schools
georgetown day school just like the
religious school that justice barrett
was on the board of is a private school
okay so you agree critical race theory
is taught at georgetown day school i
don't know because the board is not um
the board does not control the
curriculum the board does not focus on
that that's not what we do as board
members so i'm actually not sure
as a mother
these cases involving sex crime crimes
against children
are harrowing
what i think is important to understand
is that trial judges who have to deal
with these cases
are presented with the evidence
or
descriptions graphic descriptions these
are the cases
that wake you up at night
because
you're seeing the worst of humanity
when
when there are victim statements
that are presented
when people talk about how their lives
have been destroyed
as children
how the people who they trusted
to take care of them
were abusing them in this way
and then
putting the pictures on the internet for
everyone to see
i sometimes still have nightmares about
the
main
witness the woman i mentioned earlier
who
cannot leave her house because of
this kind of fear
the vulnerability the isolation
these crimes are are horrible
and so
i take them very seriously just as i
did all of the crimes but especially
crimes against children
you've been a judge almost 10 years and
you've written more than 570
opinions
i'd say your record as a judge is the
best answer to the question what kind of
justice you will be
how would you say
your honor
that your approach to judging on the
district court relates to the way you
are now judging on the circuit court
and what approach do you think you will
bring with you if confirmed to the
supreme court
thank you senator
my approach all the way through
is one that i believe is required
by my duties by my oath as a judge
we rule without fear or favor
we are independent
as judges in our responsibilities
we
understand
at the district court level at the court
of appeals level and at the supreme
court
that judges
are restrained are constrained in the
exercise of our power under our
constitutional scheme
my methodology is designed to
help me to make decisions within those
confines
at every level it's no different now
that i'm on the court of appeals than
when i was on the district court with
respect to my understanding
of the constraints on my authority
and my responsibility
to be impartial in my rulings
on a scale of one to ten
how faithful would you say you are
in terms of religion you know i go to
church probably three times a year so
that speaks poorly of me
or dude do you attend church regularly
well senator
i am reluctant to talk about my
faith in this way just because i want to
be
mindful
of the need for the public to
[Music]
have confidence in my ability to
separate out my personal views well how
would you feel if a senator up here said
your faith the dogma lives loudly within
you and that's of concern
how would you feel if somebody up here
on our side
said you know you attend church too much
for me or your faith is a little bit
different to me
and they would suggest that it would
affect your decision
would you find that offensive
senator i'm i'm i would if i were you
i found it offensive when they said
about judge barrett
and so i guess the reason i'm bringing
all this up
is it gives me a chance to remind this
committee in america there are two
standards going on here
if you're an african-american
conservative woman you're fair game to
have your life turned upside down to be
filibustered no matter how
qualified you are
and if you express your faith as a
conservative all of a sudden you're a
effing nut
and we're tired of it
and it's not going to happen to you
but it just appalls me
that we can have such a system in
america that if a conservative woman
wants to stand out and say i love my
family just as much as you love yours
and my faith means just as much to me as
it does you that all of a sudden there
come some kind of weirdo
a guy like justice alito who's in the
same type situation you're in being in a
group doesn't agree with everything they
do or what people may say at a meeting
he didn't go to all of a sudden they own
it
this stuff needs to stop
but i'd really like you to tell us all
what are your thoughts
on what it means for our country to have
women serve in meaningful members
meaning
meaningful numbers on the federal bench
and in particular what it would mean to
have four women serving on the supreme
court for the first time in history
thank you senator
i think it's extremely meaningful
one of the things that
having
diverse members of the court does is it
provides
for the opportunity for role models
since i was nominated to this position
i have received so many notes and
letters
and
photos from
little girls around the country
who
tell me
that they are so
excited
for this opportunity and that they have
thought about the law in new ways
because i am a woman because i am a
black woman
all of those things
people have said have been really
meaningful to them and
we want i think as a country for
everyone
to believe that they can do
things like sit on the supreme court